hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to death and taxes now this
is a demo for a game that allows you to
embody the personality of your very own
Grim Reaper and take those powers of
otherworldly dastardly delights in - I
don't know why I'm speaking like this
it's just the music is really magical in
very Harry Potter esque
you decide the fate of the lives of
those who are in your grasp who shall
live
who shall pay taxes only you can decide
Oh
scroll through the comic using the mouse
ooh yes indeed
is that me what a nerd what a nerd lose
nerd lemons and evil lemons
oh look here's nerd art sorry no lemons
for the yellow man that's familiar okay
lemons okay
lemons very funny very funny oh oh
that's not good
what oh ooh
magical what do you ohh oh um oh ok
finally the new spawn has awoken
what a momentous day I am honored to
welcome you into our world spawn hang on
spawn number 26
I am fate I am the keeper of world order
where am I
what is this what am i hello a pleasure
to meet you fate I don't care much for
being just 26 can I be fate oh oh these
are choices I'm a polite guy always a
charmer never caught off guard
hello a pleasure to meet you fade Oh a
polite Grim Reaper for a change that is
a good start
welcome to your new job
as an overseer of Cosmopolis city
subdivision number four the Sun County
wine region I know what you're thinking
and yes your assignment is choosing
humans who have to die pretty standard
stuff as it is your first day try to get
to know the system and try not to
destroy the world yes gallows humor is
right yes everything clear wait I have
to kill people I'm not ready for this
whatever you say boss
okay alright you got it boss I'm a
people pleaser that's the kind of
Gremory Brian delightful appreciates
solid work ethic set a dedication to the
craft now I need to tell you the details
of the job everyday I will send you the
profiles of some people your job is to
mark the files with the marker of death
choosing the people who have to die then
you fax the files back to me any
specific daily requirements will also be
noted in the letter please follow the
rules or I will have to fire you and
remember the fate of the world is in
your hands the humans you see are
constantly on a path to the great dying
they cannot balance themselves they
create endless chaos they are always on
the precipice we are here to keep the
chaos in check we are here to keep them
from falling off the precipice as such
your actions will have consequences I
was born to do this quite literally I
think you made me daddy yes yes you were
literally okay let us begin I will show
you your work place one more thing this
will be your seven day evaluation period
when the week is done you will be
assessed and IVA deemed fit or not we
cannot legislature yeah okay so one week
to show us what you're made of
I mean aside from the ingredients you
are made
very clever this fete guy very clever
ooh dais fax machina I still need to
mark some of the profile before I end my
shift Oh
lease test out my trusty phone good for
procrastinating and scrolling through
the through talker wait talker talker
talker
Caulker as in [ __ ] so like Twitter but
with Cox is it a dating app love after
death game of death coffin rent
Caulker write letter of fate morning
grim here the files on humans were in a
life-threatening situation within your
domain not difficult rules and requests
yet I am allowing you to settle in rules
for the day mark one human to perish
with the marker of death send me the
files by fax when you are done deciding
good luck on your first day fate okay an
old radio it plays one song though oh
that's not nearly as dramatic enough I'm
gonna turn that on and add my own right
here ah now that's spooky dramatic right
for the tension of judging people okay
is this a marker of death better pick it
up and start marking some files or I
know
no procrastinating let's let's go for
this Ewald a child prodigy has been
performing brain surgery since the age
of 18 I don't know if he should have
been doing that that that seems like
something he should not have been doing
they are well established as a medical
professional in academia and in practice
Ewald is addicted to adrenaline as it
well known for taking a great personal
risks sounds like someone was doing the
operation mid sky Mamadou has wanted to
become a firefighter since they were a
little kid as a keen wine enthusiast
Amadou is leading the strike team
fighting the wild fire threatening to
destroy sun county vineyards oh so these
are the only two that I have to choose
between there's a nurse wasn't there
something yeah
massive wildfire threatens to engulf the
whole wine region of Sun County okay so
if this is what I think it is then the
math here is simple there's currently a
crisis going on therefore I should save
this one
because he's fighting the fires as much
as I love a a BASE jumping neurosurgeon
he obviously is well known for taking
great personal risks so it's not it's
not too out of the ordinary how do I
this choice is final confirm yeah yeah
the way back now unless I find something
to erase with which I don't think I can
so you're gonna die and you're gonna
live seems easy enough to me I could
make it both die but I don't think
that's how it should be done
confirm your choices Caulker you must
die okay yeah I think that's it oh there
they go
goodbye hmm oh the new death spawn
welcome how was your first day really
great great boss really good stuff that
is great to hear we are all counting on
your dedication you're doing important
work after all lives are on the line I
see exactly one person Paris today as I
asked did you figure out the best choice
I did I did I did boss I did I'm not
gonna state the obvious by telling you
there were only two options because you
know that and I'm not gonna say nobody
deserves to die because everybody does
eventually whether they deserve it or
not it's not important I did it I got it
to be honest I gave you a simple one to
start off with there really wasn't her
best choice sometimes none of the
options are good not for everyone that
is the indisputable law of Cosmos
righty-ho boss we are two peas in a pod
we are we are right on top of each other
keep your eye on the letter future
guidelines and keep up the good work a
new day awaits have you heard the saying
how'd it go
nothing is more certain then Oh shook
her head no no I haven't heard anything
like that
I was just I was literally just born at
I have never heard anything like that
Tom now it's death and taxes it's like a
a famous saying I was literally made
like not five minutes ago
you did well see you tomorrow okay boss
thank you use a good boss used such a
good boss spawn male moaning grim I hope
you found your accommodations adequate
we my phone
a doctor's worry for superbug resistance
he wrote firefighters saved vineyards
from certain doom sales of regional wine
on the rise research for experimental
surgical cure for epilepsy halted due to
grant with Cosmopolis citizen dies in
fatal to crash after tragic jetpack
malfunction what a way to go you know if
you're gonna go why not go that way
that's that's not bad I want to go out
no tragic jetpack here are the rules for
the day follow them and you will be okay
I am handing you another simple task
mark a human with an engineering or
industrial background well I mean you're
not really giving it up for merit then
are you the problems of the day is super
bug resistance which is good I guess
considering that I killed a doctor but
whatever did I kill the doctor is that
really how we're gonna say this because
I don't know if I killed the doctor ah
who do got poltroon omen 40 bicycle
repairman that screams engineer
repairing bicycles is Poulter's of life
they own a bicycle shop design and
custom bicycles and pimping up old rides
Wow
sounds cool experimental brake
modifications and neon light
installations are polar speciality
experimental brake modifications why are
you experimenting with a brake man that
sounds like something that shouldn't be
experimented with Titus is the latest
heir of a new brew pedigree as such they
managed to retire young dude all
inherited wealth these days they spend
their time lounging listless Lee in
constant and nuit I think I know what
anyway means but let me hang on a
feeling of listlessness and
dissatisfaction arising from a lack of
occupation or excitement ah all right
sounds like Titus Grove what a great
that's a great name by the way Titus
grown fantastic game Mike Jordan 73
loves bird watching a nature wrote six
books about birds lives with wife in the
city is still in good shape and goes to
dancing classes twice a week okay this
doesn't tell me what their backgrounds
were how am I supposed to know someone
with it in engineering or industrial
background I don't know I don't know am
I supposed to know none of these have
anything to do with this super bug I
think that the idea is that all these
have an industrial background and just
because this is currently a bicycle
repairment doesn't mean that that's the
only one I'm assuming that all of these
do and I think most people would
probably choose this guy just because he
seems like a like a holier-than-thou
douche but really in all honesty what is
this guy done wrong and maybe they still
have potential to do good in the world
maybe they would donate their money to
charity or something of that I'm not
saying it's likely but I think I think
the choice said I'm gonna go with his is
poor ol Mike Jordan he's 73 you know he
lived a good life he wrote books about
birds loves bird-watching you know like
a wife but you know hey you know your
time is come and this guy's
experimenting with brakes that's that's
rad that's rad and if there ever was
someone with an industrial engineering
background it's the person who loves
bird-watching listen you're 73 yet a
good life it's it's the way of the world
you know and these guys you know they
got they got a lot left to contribute
they got it they got they got this
yeah they got this all right cool we're
good I feel good about this I don't feel
good but you know yeah I mean I
shouldn't feel good right it'd be weird
if I felt really good right now it
wouldn't it you are grim how's your
second day on the job great loved it
boss loved it
I am glad so did you follow the rules
properly yeah absolutely
I you know me I got you bang on yes I
did great
continue with the good work and do not
let the tough choices get you down
sounds great boss sounds great
Oh No Oh No well good luck all right
thanks boss rest well you'll need it see
you soon do I sleep I think I remember
I'm just a floating skull think I'm like
a big old bag of bones
all right cool boss good talk good talk
boss good talk moaning grim a new day
dawns no special requests today
you should know the drill by now just
follow the rules and choose the
appropriate profiles then send him to me
by fax mark two humans with the marker
of death recession fears on the rise
wild fires still raging globally team
dies in a freak bicycle accident due to
brake malfunction I knew it that [ __ ]
experimenting with brakes he was playing
with forces beyond his control he was
being a dick and to be perfectly honest
I should have known that I should have
known but hey it's only one team dying
versus anything else are the person I
marked for death probably was gonna like
make all the birds rampage through the
city streets and kill everybody
Carrie Haven botanist gardening is
Carrie's favorite pastime and also their
line of work they enjoy growing edible
exotic plants and experimenting with
different recipes they are also an
expert in natural poison sounds like
poison ivy to me sounds real weird I
like it paetynn justice a trained writer
but always struggled to find work when
they aren't trying to find a job they
enjoy writing rap lyrics about street
life look I'm not one to make a judgment
call here I just say who lives or dies
so you do what you do you man and Peyton
if you want to go out in the streets and
rap about the realities of life you do
that Columbo hunter god these are such
great names
I gotta admit these names are strong
names Columba hunter Peyton justice keel
fin Cheney that's Columba is a
distinguished war veteran these days a
well regarded passenger airline pilot
they have five children and a wife as a
hobby Columbia is very interested in the
history of religious buildings if I mark
to die they're gonna have a mid-air
heart attack yeah ain't gonna be good
healed decided to return to school to
finish their education after their four
kids grew up and went to find their own
paths while progress is difficult after
such a long pause keels dedicated
diligent when not at school they write
slam poetry hell yak he'll Cal a Jackson
Buick daga project manager Jackson just
doesn't seem to get a break they manage
various projects which all end up
failing they used to be married but
nothing lasts forever their pet goldfish
died one day their bike always seems to
have a flat tire and this is just the
beginning just the beginning sounds like
the origin story for a super villain
if you ask me listen Jackson seems to be
the type of person that all these things
is either gonna lead them to become a
really well-adjusted member of society
unlikely or a super villain and frankly
Jackson P Ortega look I I think I think
you know these are all signs pointing in
the right direction because you're my
number one okay none of these are gonna
be easy clear-cut choices so I got to
make up the choices for myself I think
Carrie haven this is the start of
poisoning everybody the wine country
cannot risk a rogue botanist out there
harassing the countryside with their
varieties of poisonous grape I will not
have this you die don't ask me again I
know what I'm doing
get out of here listen you've been
having a bad run you know I don't want
to upset the status quo of your life I
don't know if there's another
mythological entity that's here to get
all these bad things happening to you
but look man you're already in the deep
end so why not go deeper cool see it
alright
you kept heal you've get that degree
heal our Columba you keep going buddy
alright Peyton you write about the
realities of the street man you don't
let anybody get you down especially not
me okay cool yeah that I feel good about
that I don't know if I should feel good
about that but it feels really good to
pass judgment on these people that I
don't know Grimm my latest partner good
evening three days you have spent with
us how do you feel awesome getting
things done keeping the world in balance
I feel hungry all the time God doing
great boss it couldn't be better
everything literally mom full of lemons
but I'm turning it into lemonade now I'm
pissing out a fresh glass I slugged it
down with a couple Ice Cube every
morning I feel great boss excellent that
is what I hope to hear literally word
for word I hope to hear that it is
important to keep morale up in our line
of work as you may imagine now let me
take a look at the files you send in
today right everything seems to be in
order you have followed the rules and
marked the correct amount of profiles
there really is not much else to say you
may leave good night see you tomorrow
great good [ __ ] boss good [ __ ] all right
how squawker doing absolutely nothing oh
there it is
hostile language fading in politics Oh
developing countries improve sanitation
Oh woman accidentally Rams ex-husband
with car all right all survived in a
plane crash debut collection by young
poet justice max released to rave
reviews and widespread acclaim local
poet breaks through tough scene Oh
municipal gardener found dead in their
own home cause of death is unclear its
plants the plants did it how do you
looked outside today it rains it has
been raining for hours appropriate to
accompany the despondence within me well
here are some rules for you
espanish words despondence feeling or
showing extreme discouraging dejection
or depression despondent about his
health fate are you feeling despondent
babe buddy of three y23 gonna die
hostile language fade this is all good
stuff good stuffs happening I am dude
I'm killing it I am killing people I am
killing people I'm destroying lives okay
who do we got
Kermit Colt [ __ ] amazing name 58
psychologist Kermit has a warm
kind-hearted personality and does their
best to help troubled youth and
marginalize people there are community
activists and run a private practice for
cognitive behavioral therapy when they
aren't dealing with their grandkids that
sounds very noble I just need to kill
three people all right what collar
criminal growing up a boo showed great
promise and being a talented artist at
one point they shifted their efforts
towards forgeries of different types
from paintings to money at which they
are also highly skilled sounds like
someone done
julia is Mallya Hafiz names
20 from a young age Julia's dreamt of
conquering the world in order to make a
better place for animals alas so far
they have only reached basic animal
rights activism they also enjoy reading
horoscopes to people in queues sounds
real annoying not the other taking over
the world
stuff but reading horoscopes to people
in queues like come on just let people
wait in line in peace what a John Jack
Cujo Jack Cujo how was the developer
making these amazing are these just
randomly generated I hope not because
this seems like an eight like when
people find their unique talent it often
is obscured and they don't know what
their talent might be but this is mah
Jack has lived a great and kind life
they have been working in the local
beats and brothers consultancy firm for
seven years now ever since they
graduated from college recently they've
been looking for a way to turn their
life around in order to stop being an
office drone and you know people
probably making fun of him for his job
that looks like he slog down a mouthful
of bees you know okay turn your life
around that's wait does that mean you're
gonna turn your life around from being
great and kind cuz I'm reading the room
right and there were a life around
stopping an office drone mm-hmm marry
Emily lang love it architect Mary is all
about living in the present their past
long forgotten several years ago they
moved to live near the glacier at
northern point Mary has always loved
mountaineering photography sculpturing
and modern dance
how much architecture are you making up
at the glacier at northern point okay so
listen maybe you shouldn't have been
such a for juror and listen maybe you
shouldn't be reading horoscopes to
people in months and listen if you're
thinking about turning your life around
that leads to a road of excitement and
then drugs hard sex rock and roll the
devil's lettuce like I could see you go
in a bad way Jack Cujo
you are like number one of my deserve to
die like you lived a great and kind life
looking for a way to turn their life
around no way on office drone till the
day you die which is today really
reading to people in queues I mean I
don't care if you read horoscopes in
your spare time
leave people in queues alone I don't
care about all the animal rights stuff
whatever you do you concur in the world
you haven't done it yet I don't even
care just leave people in lines alone
wish you will cuz you're dead come warm
kind out at personnel this guy seems too
nice oh yeah let me look at this does
our best help troubled youth and
marginalized people they are community
activists and run a private practice for
cognitive behavioral therapy when they
aren't dealing with their grandkids
maybe you should have dealt with your
grandkids a little less no no this guy's
gonna live it's yeah it's clear alright
North Pole hey you pay attention to that
North Pole you you need to and then a
boot look you should not have made so
many error Onias decisions maybe you can
find a way to forge this into a life
thing alright cool good happy about that
let's do this yeah put them away get out
of here I don't even want to see them
get them out we're in there you are
let us be quick all the profiles are
here just as requested excellent work
I'm beginning to sense a tinge of pride
growing within me I did not expect you
to turn out to be such a good and
dedicated Reaper if you keep this up you
will get far you may be even promoted to
a middle management position imagine the
possibilities I'm imagining them boss
I'm imagining a mum anyway I'm quite
busy tonight so you can go until
tomorrow grim
you got it boss hey you want some
lemonade fresh pissed woo banks in
trouble as stimulus halted increase
funding to combat superbugs promising
young Arctic winds grand prize for
monumental sauna murder suicide note
reads I was wronged in the worst way
possible stealing food that was left in
the office fridge a crime most heinous
absolutely low-cost dorms under
investigation as student dies of
hypothermia famous forger found dead in
apartment possible mob hits suspected
editorial by young psychologists
inspires anti-bullying movement I'm
great
only two are you sure it is but a Monday
and day nothing out of the ordinary
going on a regular day in the usual
district of a typical planet to to die
really just to are you sure about that
just to you only want to you sure you
don't want more than two Jewell gray
Bob can this jewel is born in the
countryside but moved to a big city for
a university likes rock concerts and
bars tries to find a cure for the
chicken flu has had issues with
substance abuse in the past oh well
maybe you shouldn't have been a
biochemist Walter White you're gonna
make meth I know Nora Sophia Ito I don't
even know if I'm pronouncing that right
but I love that name Nora turn to
regular embezzlement after their
multi-level marketing scheme failed
all right that's a bad right off the
start not good the beauty products and
cognitive enhancers were just not
selling all this to pay off their Morgan
to keep their children in a decent
school
Nora films claymation shorts in their
spare time well that's fair I get it you
got to provide for your kid
but MLM really Elora Harnick doesn't
even make sense but I love it choir
singer Laura is a professional singer
who joined the church choir at their
local town they offered their signe
skills to the church partly to be more
devout and partly to have better access
to the church wine cellar you know hey
God drink that blood of Christ you got
do dat I don't know my church has a
whole wine cellar but hey party on God
shahi Hunter don is beta living a
hunting wild game for decades recently
they've become fascinated with
conspiracy videos on meat tube convinced
there's a monster living in the nearby
swamp you might be right about that I
mean if anyone would know it'd be the
hunter in the wild I have hunted Bigfoot
so I'm not gonna put that against you
Christi Kapil look at the five head on
this lady her head is half face he said
half for Jesus Christ a true student for
life Christi has no intention of
stopping their intense learning process
in fact they might be on the verge of
massively important breakthrough with
their fourth bachelor's thesis
I mean hey look with a brain that size
you can't deny I mean her brains
practically pushing the rest of her head
down all right [ __ ] mokou diya that
sounds familiar game sign it just said
that hajima comes up with new ideas for
new games characters and plot lines by
meditating in the rain subsequently to
their game seems to make less and less
sense yet still somehow getting better
well well well mr. cotija hajima we'll
see about that
all right whatever I think what it's
doing it's it's presenting me with
things that are more even but I can
pick these things out of a lineup listen
MLM claymation I don't think so I don't
think so I don't think so Nora that
ain't that just ain't happen all right
you like to get crunk I cannot deny that
listen that might be Shrek over there
you go hunt what's a little being
convinced there's a monster within there
might be a monster I'm the Grim Reaper
weirder things have happened okay you
live Christie Kapow breakthrough not
even a question you put that humongous
brain to good use Tajima kudia and joule
gray listen I can pick out a future
meth-dealing you're gonna shave your
head you're gonna recruit some
high-school dropout you're gonna start
cranking out meth it's gonna lead to a
lot of people dying and a great TV show
but I'm cutting this off at the pass you
get out of there all right cool ma'am I
this is I am I would be such a good Grim
Reaper I am the best
what a day grim what a day now let us go
over your conduct first good I have the
correct amount of mark brofist
everything seems to be in order
anyway grim you have been here for a
number of days all I'd ask how does it
feel to make such difficult choices not
gonna lie to you boss love this if
honestly you could give me more like
baseline stuff I can pick him apart it's
like I was born to do this I can see the
evil in their souls right from a
distance their picture get me too just
give me three words that our name I know
exactly what they are who they will be
and how they deserve to die I could kill
them for you you want me to do that give
me a knife whereas my scythe I'll slice
them right in twice to be honest I feel
like I'm not killing people I got not
gonna lie to you boss I feel like I
could go through about dozen or more I
crave more give me that [ __ ] come now
don't be ridiculous take the job
seriously we're not here just end people
that hazard Li not haphazardly boss I'm
gonna be very methodical about it but I
know I'm like a machine built for this
just give me quantity of cranky out
accuracy no no lie but consider the
humans in this context do you think this
is an appropriate way to deal with them
yeah how else you gonna do it how is he
gonna do it yep
well I don't question the system I'm a
doer you tell me what to do I don't
quite I'm not questioner I don't I'm not
an Oscar I'm a doer okay with such
certainty perhaps or no you may be
correct this might be the way forward
why rock the boat death and taxes you
said it not me I just do the lemonade
thing you do not think it unethical to
make the choices you make all this
control over so many lives
unbeknownst to humans themselves listen
listen I'm not that I like I said I'm
not to ask her to be honest you're the
one doing this I you hand out the rules
I don't need to know I don't need to
know you do it you do the
decision-making it I don't do it -
enough one must be in charge the others
will follow I've never heard better
words in my life boss I'm a follower
you're the doer I don't ask you do the
asking I just judge nice cat by the way
just notice that buried pretty love the
eyes our offices perennial and highly
venerated we have spent eons crafting
our methods and strategies we get what
we're doing yes yeah as a guy who's only
been around for what like 40 minutes I
ask questions but I don't ask questions
oh I do apologize for taking up so much
of your time before you go are there any
questions you'd like to ask me yeah I
haven't seen any young profiles where's
the little uns you know like have you
ever seen Star Wars Episode three you
know Anakin went into the temple and all
the kids were like mr. Anakin what's
running and the lightsaber kicked on and
I was like yeah and then they cut away
from it but I can imagine what happened
where's a little bit of that you know
what I'm saying Oh children yes there
are a special case something for a
different set of departments do deal
with joke joke no one read into that too
much listen you're not here to judge me
I'm the judge here I don't ask I just do
I'm not the guy given the order 66
listen I that's the Emperor this guy's
the Emperor I'm Anakin not just the
men women and the chill
I must stop you will not find any
yourself
I will not are you sure there are many
other offices and departments countless
and they all have Reapers working in
them listen I was just saying I could do
it all
myriad whoa Wow Wow
exactly anything else what's the basis
for the profiles is there a point system
oh not at all
you don't sound too ok then you know I'm
not gonna question what about animals to
the year Department absolutely all
living beings have to be processed after
the end there is no escape even plants
yes there's the department for plants do
not ask about the plant Department say
no more boss what about the unliving
things buildings and stuff technically
are kind of I guess ruins are like a
type of dead but at the same time they
often feel alive this topic is too
abstract for now we may have to return
to it for a later date
I want to get back to work boss let me
get back to it right it has been
enlightening yeah I bid you good night
see you tomorrow alright boss love you
Oh oops
sorry love you that's our joke okay boss
alright doctors worry for super bug
resistance scandal erupts a scandal
erupts at university as another scandal
erupts at university as another thesis
found to be full of praise plagiarized
paragraphs and faulty research yeah
makes my plastic cog ashes series of
games soon to get another sequel up to 7
now a young biochemist dies in a fire at
work his chicken flu ever finding a
vaccine you must see this video of a
laughing man dressed as Indiana Jones
stealing a royal chicken from the store
our small-town prodigy moved to the city
we say reach for the stars scientists
very close to figuring out how to
connect unter a dangerous pathogen we
seem to be on the precipice of dark
times I may have warned you that this
job can have some harsh moments today's
that day no prob for me boss listen
there is no trouble here mark total of
six humans mark at least two younger
humans mark any humans with a medical
background alright let's start from the
back this time
all right Jake Bartowski Jake is what
defines young what are we talking about
young here should I just go with the
youngest it says two it says
- younger humans but younger is younger
x' in the back row olders in the front
row got let's start with the youngins
okay Jake a self-prescribed chemist
loves to create new recipes in their
kitchen
Jake's latest work involves mixing
opioids and uppers [ __ ] sick bro they
also enjoy showcasing their new
inventions at a local club scene
everyone knows you should be mixing up
your drugs oh boy oh it's now called
great combo this guy's gonna die the
coda is a marketing genius who could
sell barbecue ribs to a vegan what is
going on here they're exceptional talent
landed them as a job as a telemarketer
where they have single-handedly
increased profits by 200% they're
especially appealing to senior citizens
don't like you Annabelle hey Ted's
Annabelle has devoted themselves to
becoming either an astrophysicist or an
astronaut the two things are someone
related they also enjoy painting mostly
nudes computer programming and
volleyball sounds fine I guess caspere's
her sauna whoo fluffy is prominently
right handed teacher the right hand like
huge or something enjoys playing a lot
of tabletop role-playing games in the
vein of beasts and swords and cavernous
horrors of death they are deathly afraid
of bugs critters and other crawling
beasts vlag vlag Adney debug gun what I
don't know how to pronounce that name
vlog dreams of organizing a pretzel
invasion crushing the opposition across
all pastries they actively promote
pretzel supremacy pretzels shall one day
rule the land of confectionery odd
interesting okay
Serena masa Vedad electrician at 74 Wow
an avid electronics enthusiasts arena
has continued working as an electrician
well into their retirement although
their grandkids keep telling them to
retire especially due to bad AI sites
their love for the job will always win
sounds like you need to be cut off
before you like somehow managed to start
a horrible electrical fire and blow up
your entire house including your
grandkids Blair Presley ooh you know you
didn't even need to tell me their job I
could have picked that out from the
picture alone plastic surgery in an
adult film director right Blair
considers their job as a doctor more of
a hobby enjoy traveling to various
foreign lands and shooting movies movies
you say given their regular travel
agenda they
three wives in three yeh hama immune
ologist for the past 15 years ei is
spent every day working in a windowless
concrete bunker testing various vaccines
in order to eradicate some of the
deadliest diseases in the world during
off times they enjoy lengthy bike rides
okay
well listen you're gonna kill someone so
I gotta kill you first that's easy you
that chin alone is worth a desk see uh
let's see pretzel supreme' tea sorry I
don't actually I like pretzels they're
okay but they're a little dry for my
taste okay thank you goodbye let's see
Sarina
don't start electrical fires you're gone
Blair Presley uh listen you hope you got
life insurance policies because your
three wives are about to get a payday
you're about to be smacked by the the
beefy left hand of death look you're you
gotta go because I like only two people
can survive and that's gonna be number
one you and number two you got it done
easy yeah you thought this would be
tough the answer is wrong done is
amazing look I could be the Grim Reaper
all day I'll be the best Grim Reaper you
ever seen a Grimm are rough day lies
behind you I assume new recruits often
falter during such dark times now I'm a
boss listen not me
I was belt for the dark times I was
built for the darkness yet you seem to
have performed adequately everything is
in order how do you feel after such a
day
let's see fine I understand what needs
to be done listen you tell me what I
need to do I'll understand it whether
you give me the most obscure direction
to the world I'll turn that into logic
that will blow your mind yes good good
as we do we all we all have to do what
is necessary even if we do not fully
understand why I don't even bother
asking why let us hope that our days did
not resume what do you think even
happened listen boss don't you know what
happened you're the one that knows what
happened you're in charge after all I
you it's not me who questions what
happened I just mark the pens bubby boom
Bob got him right a hundred percent I'm
an A+ kind of guy but uh die don't
question you you know the answers yes
yes I am and yes I do
but what uses a reaper who cannot
discern the situation from the choices
in front of them
that no that uh didn't know that it was
anything like it but I'm gonna guess
there's a medical calamity like an
epidemic seems like there's some kind of
super bug happen interesting and
insightful streak may yet rattle inside
that skull of yours
[Music]
boss good if I had skin I'd be blushing
right now if I had skin look I'll
emanated ah no boss you want off you go
now grim good night a good night yeah
alright see ya all right what do we got
here another tough choice only for
interesting hmm
workers suffer masse global layoffs
support centers open in mass increasing
funding to combat superbugs trees
planted in new initiative telemarketing
company bankrupt after death of key
marketer also sad
what is the astrophysics all about
anyway let me tell you a freak emu
related accident claims the life of a
young teacher should've been messing
around with emus new vaccine that could
save countless lives nearing completion
local electrician electrocuted after
cutting the wrong wire I told you a cur
commits suicide through pretzels this
completely charity auction to take place
in rural Cosmopolis bring your friends
great love it ok perhaps we can clean up
the mess it happened yesterday that
might give you the boost that you need
boss I'll boost it up every day I go
into work is another day that I'm happy
remember many troubles left behind the
many may lie ahead or to humans with
that marker of death spare humans that
might help against the troubles ok
Malthus under guard Mavis's a
grandparent with an estranged grandchild
named guy with whom they would seek to
reconcile after retirement they moved to
a calm country home where they spent
most of their time knitting they own a
marvelous collection of porcelain
sounds like someone's not an
immunologist Charlie dock fraud CEO how
do you be a Francia a CEO that committed
fraud Charlie has been helping their
brother Albert David hide corporate
money and avoid paying taxes for years
perhaps even decades they have also been
accused of insider trading and other
fraudulent activities they currently
live in a mansion just outside of town
hug someone
[Applause]
Victor Yasha and Victor graduated at the
top of their class and made a fast climb
on the career ladder becoming the chief
safety inspector of local nuclear power
plants they have already spotted several
mistakes possibly preventing many
actions that's important
alaya Sarazen chose to learn the art of
gastronomy because it felt like a decent
and stable job good food is always
needed aside from cooking they enjoy
long treks through nature and mountain
climbing hmm okay listen how I see this
Alya could be trekking through nature
mountain climbing and find a pretty
sweet plant that they're gonna use in
cooking that's gonna solve these
diseases done live no question Victor
this one's basic [ __ ] of course
fraud CEO it shouldn't have [ __ ]
around so much man all right I don't
know who Albert David did maybe Albert
David was like a name of someone before
that was like an important immunologist
but they've run out of money so I don't
know he died prior it probably was that
one all right listen
mattes listen Navis you never know when
you're gonna go get a reconcile sooner
this is the first one that feels bad but
you know everybody there may be
something where Albert David is the name
of someone who was like someone
researcher or something like that I
don't even remember the locker room it
is time for your ultimate performance
review for the trial period let me get
my papers first up let us see the
possible good you may have managed to
create in the world
congratulations give grim seems like man
Kanye's postponed bombing itself into
the ground for now there's a lot of
scrap metal around now though a lot and
who knows what they're going to do with
all this spare uranium I think I might
need it for no matter just an idle fault
yes everything okay boss everything good
are you good you're good and you need
anything patience grim I'm contemplating
your continued existence Hey look look
boss if I gotta go with my papers up
there listen no hard feelings you marked
the marker of death on me I ain't gonna
question it I'm not an ass Kerr like
I've said well it appears that you have
indeed kept the Kaos away
for now you have performed adequately
thanks boss thanks that you know that's
all like that praise it's like the Word
of God and you may be God I don't know
who am I just said maybe the cat's God
I'm not one to question thank you in the
world oh do not thank me grim I'm not
the one holding the marker nor will I
ever do not let this cloud your judgment
you still have much to learn and many
rules to follow it's cake
I like ice cream oh I'm just saying I
like ice cream boss yeah and if you were
thinking about getting me a little
reward for good I like ice cream what I
swear there must have been something off
in the grim brew nonetheless you'll keep
working for me since your trial had been
successful you may have a bright
eternity ahead of you that is all
goodbye for now Grimm hey you want some
lemonade before you go okay alright that
that was fun I like that I don't know if
I just like passing judgment on people
but that was pretty cool get back to
real life
only a 37th of 32.7 passed the player
trial period successfully nice that was
great III super enjoyed that wait I have
an idea there's a secret achievement
called fates pet and it says get a raise
I'm gonna try something real quick dad
dad goodbye don't even need to know I
don't even want to know awesome
I killed everyone dad dad dad goodbye
see round felt like the right thing to
do dad gone Batta Batta smitheroons top
pieces you go done
I'm disappointed over the second time I
say rid of myself if you do many Paris
results will be disastrous let's see I'm
look so sorry boss
apologize to those lives are lost there
will not be many more okay
second warning interesting interesting
boss okay good you know what it listen
it's not my fault a the slip of the
marker listen all right dad Melissa get
out of here Oh get out of here get out
of here
Get gone these are different people all
right whatever
yeah whatever get
on whatever get him out I don't want to
see him disgusting pavers on it you
cannot continue this leaves slope of
annihilation delivering third and final
Mars I will be forced to terminate you
or contract down do your job properly
you got it boss boss listen you say
things I understand them that's how it
works
oh god dad gone get away from me
no get gone you again go bye easy peasy
lemon squeezy
what a day what did they conduct too
many profiles excess death is to be more
careful yeah I feel like I'm not killing
enough they don't be ridiculous they'll
listen listen humans do you think it's
proper of course we're dead marker kill
him efficient great oh yeah
finally boss recognizing my talents
thank you thank you thank you very much
boss okay all right cool good gone go
buy her go buy your MD and the world is
in ruins
let's first terminate your contract you
list because what else would you do
hopefully a next death Braun will have
some merit oops
well that definitely didn't get me to
where I needed to go got fired for
insubordination yeah it seems fair okay
wait I have an idea I think it must be
like some kind of the the last
achievement must be something about like
a perfect playthrough so I'm gonna I'm
gonna Dan and then like economic boom
happening right now to be frank this
quite helpful
oh no the balance is completely off I
have not seen anything like this since
how bad did it how many pages of this Oh
what what I can't even believe the mess
you have create the world is in shambles
whoo toxic spills everywhere the force
of it you were given a sacred dance
together you only brought ruin as if the
whole design is currently stacked
against me fish as if that's like stupid
to delude excuse your accomplice yes if
only you had made better choices now go
to your room and you're fired I'm fired
what fine I'll leave but mark my words
I'll return to save your place
weird what a weird one what master of
chaos oops I guess you were supposed to
make intelligent choices okay so that
was death and taxes that was really fun
the full game comes out February 20th
which is right around the corner and it
features a lot more like customization a
lot of different things that could
happen a lot of like other environments
to go through not just about like doing
that death thing this seems to be a
counter and also a globe that kind of
gives you an idea of what's going on
so there probably is like a good way to
play and there probably is a perfect
answer and it'd be pretty low as when I
was playing I was kind of making
decisions willy-nilly so there probably
is a perfect way to play so thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to play this for yourself link to
the demos in the description below
there's also links to many other videos
that I made about cool games so check it
out down there thanks everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]